[Music]
[Applause]
uh Scott Van Pelham ESPN SportsCenter
anchor golf host and kind enough to wake
up after working last night uh van Peezy
great to have you on thank you what was
your first reaction yesterday at uh 10
Eastern thought it was fake
daughter's fake
um
just because that's sort of what I think
you know Twitter sort of trains us not
to buy much
um but obviously quickly you determine
pardon me that well this is this is a
real thing and it's it's it's stunning
and I was thinking about this last night
and this morning and chatting with you
that you know we've both been fortunate
to be at this for a while and there are
moments real actual real bombshell news
news
um moments that you just think wow
there's I mean whoa rather there's a lot
of wow Moments in Sports this was a whoa
because just the things that the
commissioner had said
um using you know 911 as a reason never
to be in business with with
um the Saudi fund and then now hey now
these are great guys here we go I mean
it and he
what he said yesterday about you know
you dealing with the information that
he's got and that things change well
it's not what changed here yeah I mean
you connect the dots and you could
certainly look to litigation which is
costly and discovery which I don't think
either side's particularly interested in
um but my reaction was just that I was I
was amazed given the rhetoric
um and given the the specific things
that that commissioner Monahan had said
that this was the direction that they
went and I can tell you his his players
were as well
what bothers you the most
well
look just to be clear when it comes to
business
I'm rarely troubled by what people
decide to do they the players that went
to live they had in some cases
nine-figure decisions to make and I
never held that against anyone because
I've never had that decision to make and
many of the people that will you know
very you know
um
vociferously moralize about that and
their lives have not been confronted
with that so I find that very difficult
business to do
all the all that bothers me is if when
you say you say one thing that is here
and then this is 180 degrees removed
from that it's not slightly different
it's the exact opposite and I bother I
don't know that it bothers me it
interests me to know what it is and I
don't necessarily know that those
answers will be coming to to say well
you know look it's it was it's always
the money man right it's always the
money in some form or fashion so is it
simply a matter that the tour recognized
that if this was going to be an arms
race related to Dollars it was not a
battle there could be won in the long
game
how do you think the PGA Tour is going
to look in a year and a half two years
from now
that's the question that some of the
biggest players in the game and I were
talking about yesterday you know it's
funny and again you could relate you
know you you know the people in the
business and mostly
I think mostly it's we you know you text
back and forth yesterday was one of
those things you text somebody and
instantly you'd see the name pop up
because the phone's ringing because this
is a conversation more than it's a text
thread and I'd ask them what what and
they'd say to me well what do you think
it's going to look like and I'm you're
asking me I mean I don't know I can't
think
that the live model will exist as in you
know golf but louder and 54 holes and
shorts and shotguns I mean and listen by
the way shorts it's hot in the summer
we'll learn more shorts who gives a game
yeah but I can't think that that model
will exist there was in the press
release something about The A Team
aspect being part of it now does that
mean there would be certain events much
like Zurich right in New Orleans which
is a two-man team event might there be a
team component
um I I think there probably will be uh I
might would be my guess but what I don't
know is currently I don't believe Live
players and PGA Tour players will be
competing in the same events meaning
like this year but I mean next year are
they all sort of under the same umbrella
competing in events I think at some
point they'd have to be because I
believe that's what the fund was buying
uh in a sense or investing in they don't
own an outright but they're the largest
investor because you you bought players
but on live you just didn't have the
distribution where you were being
consumed as a product right you needed
to have it you need to have a television
partner where you had eyeballs they
didn't have that
um and yeah I get that they've got a
bottomless well of money but at some
point you just you want to spend it on
something that feels like an actual
investment that's a product being
consumed at large and I think that that
has to happen at some point
um but you asked in a year is it a year
I don't know because I you know Dan I
don't know what I don't know in terms of
the contracts how long do they run this
changes everything from a TV perspective
I would think if you're CBS or NBC or
whoever has paid for one thing well now
it's going to be in a different entity
which I think this new entity is going
to sit down and say or let's talk about
what it's going to cost to have us on
your air and these are I'm just all
thinking out yeah
things I think are reasonable aren't
they well I also wondered about this
policy board where you have five players
who were on the policy board so you got
Rory on the policy board there does that
does does the commissioner have to run
this by anybody
apparently not
um or or maybe he is Rory the one person
who was privy to some of these
conversations it wouldn't shock me if he
were I mean he he traffics at the
highest levels of um of you know people
that run companies and are you know he's
a thoughtful bright guy that who I like
a lot and he was the guy that I kept I
always kept saying you know that Jon
Snow like GIF or whatever he pulls out
the sword he's like I'll fight I'll
fight everybody from Game of Thrones I
felt like that was Rory last summer and
if he really like all the rest of these
guys woke up yesterday to find out this
had happened well then you've done him
dirty man because you let him do carry
all your water last summer and and then
this happened so if he did know if he
was the one guy that knew something that
to me would have been honestly
reasonable given what he did for the
tour last year but the commissioner put
these players in a difficult position
hey you don't take money that's blood
money and look at what they did with 911
so now you're in the position edition of
you have to take that money if you're
going to continue to be a professional
golfer correct you he he took the money
he forbid them from taking and banned
them from taking if they took it and if
they're if players just if it was
loyalty to the tour if it was
um a belief that that was money they
didn't want a part of
well tough tough I don't know if I'm
allowed to cuss here
um it's too bad because now that now
you're we're I'm taking it so by by
proxy so are you
um so but he he put him he put out he he
put himself in the toughest spot and I
don't know if it's survivable I mean I I
don't know I mean I I was told last
night
um that in the meeting that when a call
for his for for new leadership came that
it was greeted with warm uh Applause
um and people are going to be pissed
especially yesterday when this comes out
of nowhere the thing that I keep coming
back to is that
we often don't know what we don't know
and when you get a look at what this
will mean
um perhaps there's there's uh there's a
windfall that is that is such that the
rank and file go oh I see why this was
done I understand why this was done
um but but without that we're currently
operating on well how's this work again
yeah I couldn't take 10 million 20
million in some cases a nine figure deal
I don't know what the tiger offer was
for real
um but I don't care I don't care how
rich you are the money that they were
offering him what is life-changing money
even for a really rich dude and he
didn't take it yeah we're just trying to
figure out the context of this it's
basically hey this is happening we're
not quite sure what the future is going
to hold or we're not going to tell you
that I I want to know what Jay Monahan
got
I mean sure this is all transactional
Scotty and I always I mean that's always
again I I was only half kidding when I
you know when I quoted Nino Brown from
New Jack City and it's you know always
business never personal so I mean it in
Monahan's case is it self-preservation
um is it to give himself some soft
landing spot I don't know I I don't I
don't know any of that what happens to
Greg Norman
that's another really interesting one
because I think you know Alan shipnick
who's got the book coming out on it um
he's been as is up to date as anybody on
all of this uh and the guys from no
laying up who do a great job I think all
of them were uh I believe like right to
point out that when it was revealed that
Greg found out about it just before they
went on CNBC and really wasn't mentioned
in the um
in the press release is having a role
um I I don't is he is he part of it I I
don't know
um but I think and again I would if
people are interested in our
conversation I think Alan wrote a really
interesting piece sort of about his
perspective on the winners and the
losers and why Greg was really
Vindicated here because as you know so
well you've been covering golf for so
many years this has always been Greg's
thing yeah it goes back decades that
this was something he kind of wanted to
do and
um it seems that Monahan essentially
took yesterday what he what he said
would never happen just a couple of
years ago and they could have avoided
all of this had they done it and Norman
pushed for it all these years and um you
know some version of it is going to end
up happening it's like when Steve Jobs
got pushed out at Apple you know Greg
Norman started this then brought in Phil
and Phil became sort of the de facto
commissioner of the live tour and you
didn't need Greg anymore I just wonder
if Jay Monahan is going to be in
position uh in the next couple of years
Greg Norman probably uh kicked to the
curb here a little bit appears right
yeah it appears so
um but I mean I guess as you point out
in whatever industry that that you might
look at at the highest levels when
things happen like this are the P are
all the people that are the part of the
beginning of it part of the end of it
and the success of it maybe not uh but I
mean already at warp speed we went from
from one to the other uh of where things
now are but again
where they where are we I honestly I
don't know
um which makes it such kind of I mean
interesting but but again just to
reiterate in talking to players at the
highest level of the game yesterday to
hear them as
um
baffled me I mean in the just just I
don't know they did what's this gonna
look like what do you think it's gonna
look like and uh that's a wild place to
be when you're asking the guys who
passed on the big dough uh to just kind
of Buy in and then you don't tell them
what it is and then they wake up one
Tuesday morning to a reality that's
entirely different that's that's a lot
to ask guys to sort of accept yeah I
corresponded with a golfer yesterday and
he said what do you know and I said boy
that's sad if you're asking me what do I
know and he goes we don't know what I
said exactly what I said I said dad you
know you understand I'm on cable at
midnight I'm just I'm just a humble your
humble cable servant I'm not I'm not I'm
not here to uh tell you the specifics
for 501c politicking I don't know man
great to talk to you thanks for getting
up no problem dance my pleasure hope
you're well that's uh Scott Van Pelt
ESPN SportsCenter anchor and of course
uh golf host